hello everybody and welcome to let's
play slender okay I have been inundated
literally people have been messaging me
day and night writing in every comment
of every video I've ever posted since
slender got released to play slender so
welcome to let's play slender I'm
finally playing I haven't even seen a
screenshot of this game let alone a
video because the website where the game
was supposed to be hosted is down
probably because everyone on the
internet is trying to play it right now
so I had like find it off a redirect of
a server of a comment post on reddit so
I finally got it though it's not up yet
so don't panic like oh it's black screen
no it's not up yet so it is it's in the
unity engine so after it doesn't have a
main menu so I have to load separately
but anyway I have no idea what I'm
getting myself into
so let's find out all right and I've
read the readme you know just but that
just told me how to move sprint left
shift to sprint ginge parsec for this -
and it was left click to collect pages
and right click to turn on and off your
flashlight so I got that presents what
are you presenting well you got bring it
on already
I mean people been saying is like the
scariest game they've ever seen in their
entire life or something like that
blender and I don't know I played
amnesia penumbra a mouse crap here I'm
afraid of monsters so let's find out
collect all eight pages well I'm in the
woods it's not what I was expecting
but eight pages that actually reminds me
of another game that I'd played a while
ago it wasn't anywhere near good looking
at this I mean this actually looks
really nice it was amazing the Unity
engine so it's like that that's free to
make free to play or free to share
freeware game building a software it has
all the tools necessary and just create
your own objects put them in the game
make rules
actually anyway this reminds me of
another game that I was that I played a
while ago called hide hide was what it
was called it was it wasn't the graphics
didn't look anywhere near as pretty I
mean was really low res stuff I mean not
pretty at all but it was it would like
this you were in the woods and there
were these monsters with flashlights so
try and find you and collect pages and
when you collected more pages a
helicopter would come everything will
try harder to find you got harder and
harder to get away so I'm wondering just
through inspiration a big red tree ah
giant red dildo jutting out of the
ground here hey John no alright seems
weird that this thing would just be
shutting out of the ground here and
nothing on it or about it alright
whatever it's just a big good thing and
I got all the way around
from the ground nothing okay that's cool
all right that's nice maybe that's like
the Slenderman home
I've heard very minimal about the
Slenderman like he's just some something
that is like in a suit follow you
how's it feel you sounds like that I
mean I'm in the woods
this isn't terribly frightening right
now what was that I mean there's no
music or anything
what I mean some games don't need music
I'm not seeing a wait what's that
Oh what I see some and ah that looks
like a page leave me alone no I will not
blender man sorry sorry I didn't want to
bother ya just once a page let's see
anything else gonna respond while I'm
playing yeah anything
bring it on something out there anybody
in the woods when I mess with me you
don't know what you're getting self into
I don't know what I'm getting myself
into
it's just like fence why is there just
fence no wait Paige Paige Paige I'm
guessing all the pages are gonna be on
these unique landmarks Paige what ha ha
Wow what my screen went fuzzy I saw a
dude is that him well that's a guy well
that's the guy oh okay I didn't see a
page on the thing hang on that dude I
gotta check this other side ah Paige
true you helped me after you
ah got your page doosh doosh yeah here
don't like you anyway well I'm hearing
fuzzies whatever is over there so I'm
guessing you look over them too long
it's fuzzy that's actually kind of how
it wasn't hide that game I was talking
about earlier you if you looked at an
enemy for too long I think it was that
sort of a gang no actually I don't know
it was all I wanted it saw you when
you're at risk of being seen then it got
fuzzy because if it saw you pretty much
game over from that point on I you know
I may play that game but it's not pretty
to look at
like not like this right there
it's not bothering me it's just watching
him anything at all what's that
is that another page oh yeah
don't look or it takes you well I
figured that out on my own okay I get it
so as what was that
that's the as you get more pages the
atmosphere builds up the tension I like
that what where where I don't see him
what where oh oh he's right there oh hi
buddy hey hey how's it go oh hey how's
it going buddy hey Rand I'm gonna go
into the building right now there right
there
chair picture I'm really concerned that
you gotta come in this building there
might be a dead end or something
oh oh he's coming in the building he's
coming to Terra
tell me please please please help me
Sheriff oh don't corner me bro don't
corner me I got a way out what ha can't
run can't run you're damn right because
I'm not an Olympic athlete in this game
for two seconds I'm done I don't know
what is mechanical whoa oh whoa whoa
is he there I heard fuzzies the deal
Emilio Emilio ah about it found it on
your page
okay all right bro yeah it's all good oh
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no I said no outfit no uh-huh
watch the tree lock you with a greedy
uh-huh okay get me around a tree
I got no no I don't matter anyway to
tell where I've been or where I'm going
ah honey and Remy playing and Remy
how do you breathe of Radio Free Press
Oh screw you guys
no I said howdy there hanging in there I
see you damn I shouldn't see him not
seeing him in the bad thing how the
Frick you've wrecked me to get there
hi yeah I need that like I can keep it's
close to when I'm not looking at him
he's done his general correction where
am I going
I don't even know I don't even I don't
even know I don't even know
where am I
like where am i where
I'm back at the gas tanks cranky ha ha
honey in there
honey you there how did he get there how
do you get there you still left did you
see him
I saw him we're not looking I'm not
looking at
Oh No
I'm gonna win this game get my pages
my pages are gonna be paper cut
away go there are no how still not
seeing anything
Oh
Oh Dom get away get away way likes you
you have no friends
ugly skinny default Gus thumbs the
scrawny guy
whatever seemed to keep him at bay
another clearing
oh yeah bye
ah how do you there well I shouldn't ask
how he got there anymore because
obviously teleporting son of a [ __ ] oh
god this time no gimme this time not any
time back right off
I seem to be that
ah God
look he's supporting closer and closer I
swear must be it must be like some sort
of time mechanism man okay running out
of time I have been taking forever to
find this six page
I don't know what the deal is I'm back
at the big red dildo aah
get back here
Oh get back here no page here ha
was there no Bezier check please also
run around so I blocked the Slenderman
no no there was not
[Music]
ha spread version
right there right there
I got buck user that's right
by not blocking [ __ ] not working I ain't
getting fuzzy oh boy he's there I said
no I don't want any
Jesus please you bastards
lady I don't lady you're not lady are
your lady but
I'm back at the red dildo again what is
this the thing this is missing
why why why why do I keep ending up here
are they multiple ones of these he's
like a lie this is the Puerto Bob listen
go buddy
bitch-slap to the next Center
I need a block I need to make some
progress
no if I knew where I was going I could
have gotten all basically done this game
crying
Fuzzy's I hear the buzzy I didn't see
any but I heard the buzzing
Oh
oh he's getting closer he's getting
closer again you're getting close down
to make some distance distance distance
distance
I gotta find Paige gotta find a page to
page
Klose Darius off the fence again all
right it screw it I'm just gonna fall
the fence in a big circle I think it
just offensive erupts all bugs flown in
my ear that was my nose not my ear I
know what my nose BRR
I owe him
I'm going overtime
ah what the game crashed the crashed why
did it crash ah
good thing I'm recording the video and
audio separately this time okay
well that sucked that really sucked I
was actually oh ah alright fine
um I'm gonna get back in and I'm gonna
get it this is gonna be a long long
let's play but I want to give this real
try and Simon didn't even get me so
that's no fun it's not fun if I'm not
gotten so there we go alright so grind
this again give it a real try I don't
know what I mean it is an indie game so
obviously software might not be perfect
but anyway one do get the landmarks I
know little house the gas the stones
like Stonehenge the big tube and that
weird square circle plus sign you
wouldn't shape and I'm gonna go around
the fence Slenderman isn't there for the
beginning so I I'm pretty okay here okay
alright my game that sucks but I mean
what are you gonna do what happens I've
been I've been having so many problems
with my computer I swear that it's just
been non-stop barrage of problems who
bets I run into the big red dildo first
oh no what's that
that's fine in a different place cuz
there's a building I think that you're
doing yeah that's the building okay cool
must be randomly generated or something
anyway yeah I've been having so many
problems I'm with the audio problems
with Skyrim and everything and then
recording problems like some episodes
that recording there's no audio at all
so I've just made a habit of recording
my
separately from now on so and I just
line it up all later
there's no Slenderman until I find that
hello chair you have a note on you note
the other note was in the other side I
think this is how I think it is oh yeah
yeah you can't sprint for [ __ ] I know I
know lady do some calisthenics and that
slender guy was persistent very very
persistent yeah check everywhere did not
die miss one throwing up here if the
place is randomly generated would assume
that yeah
no no okay no no that the notes would be
randomly generated also okay well let's
head out maybe in the gas gas field if
it's nearby whoa very weird like it's
not shining on us properly okay let this
wrong
oh I get it
family there oh no there it is there
okay yeah I just spawned in a different
place okay
come on they're gassing give me some
notes
give me an O give me you know you know
you know me no give me no give me no oh
come on I'm getting like no notes oh
there it is okay
oh yeah you know I'm gonna go try and
find Stonehenge it's that no don't try
to find the plus sign and maybe the big
red dildo will have something for me
there it is oh it's right there see if I
knew once I know where things are there
it is right bendy probably out there
but painting to what
get a map it was supposed to be right
here I just went it was right before you
know the fence and there's the fence
okay that's with a fence corners there's
wrong way okay ah there it is
oh there it is how could I miss it ah
help me you got it buddy I'll help you
all right now I'm just gonna follow the
fence up
Oh oh he's right there he's fun he
spawns it three bonds at three and he's
still there
oh okay i'ma fall defense up I can
follow it until I get to I know the plus
sign was in some corner followed and
Baillieu buy my stuff get out of here
win this game go home have some ice
cream nothing still back there
come on slender man man maybe maybe my
game didn't crash maybe you got me
that's always a possibility
cuz that happened in another unity in
game I was playing like the game ends
when you get got let's play again studio
8 7 the stairwell game one that was me
in the unity maybe
it's always possible I mean he was
getting closer and closer
it's almost getting boring come on give
me a real challenge boring boring
Hey look I got another corner here damn
it
it's just silly I mean people were
claiming that this game was like the
scariest ever made and so far I'm I mean
earlier ah what's this stuff stuff with
notes notes stuff noteworthy Brailler it
got a note in there anything
nope nothing nothing at all
nope nothing just have nothing I'm late
I must be getting the worst luck on
these misspelled [ __ ] won't work
where-where-where ha stop fair like I
said it is arm sticking out of a tree
gimme gimme gimme gimme a page page
Paige always watches no eyes alright
hang it ha oh that those new oh that
God there buddy
yeah I didn't think so every other
corner the other corner has the plus
sign - I'm guessing it's on the way Wow
oh hey
always getting close oh boy alright
sorry I'm collecting your pages but I
got a parent Lee for some stupid reason
I have ah there's the - man there's
gonna be a long I may break it up I
think ah hey yeah hey run
haha [ __ ] you with the dream can't give
me behind a tree ha
let see his arm nope another no it
doesn't know what I don't know what this
is
no-no-no
[Music]
no no no no I gotta find that plus sign
know where it was
three ah good only gonna hit that and
then I was gonna hit the plus sign and
then I was gonna hit one more than I
don't know where it was and then I was
gonna win I got stuck on that tree I
think there's a dim Ian all right well I
would scratch my arm in that also all
right anyway I think that's all I'm
gonna play for now so thank you guys for
suggesting it and thank you for watching
hope you liked it um and I hope this
will quell the onslaught of messages and
people asking me to play the Scooby game
not stupid game it wasn't stupid game at
all let me actually who was it Mark J
Hadley great name
mark day have we made it and his parsec
productions is his company don't play
the game and it III don't know his his
web sites probably still down but me get
like giving them a donation or something
there's something along those lines that
you can do to help him out that would be
probably be great for him
so anyway anyway that's all I'm gonna
play for now so thanks again everybody
for watching this suggesting I hope you
enjoyed it and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye